for the most important version about our
nation to staffing like this is where is
one of the biggest things they're still
going to need a real ninja there it's
like you may be thinking that I'm
watching the show but what I'm doing is
what I need to do which is I'm reading
your comment this is set it all the new
ones that are here the comments are my
oxygen I don't think people understand
how much qualitative feedback you get
from comments reading comments watching
the Explorer pages looking at how you
guys respond to my stuff than others
there's so many hours of consumption you
know I don't this is where I don't
consume shows and things of that nature
because I spend so much time reading
reading reading reading reading your
feedback you are I as a collective I can
seem you guys more than you consume me
and so I just highly recommend when you
have a small audience like you read
every one of those comments you engage
with every one of those comments brick
by brick by brick eventually you can't
reply to everybody but like you can
always read a lot I mean I read I'm just
reading all these comments David about
helping everybody get good at it not she
or he is insecure and creates a moat
around their skill set there Gary let me
just mention it
be no guarantee the beam splitter man
are you gonna fight a million real good
men feel good like me selfie Gary just
scary pleasure
all right Gary ready while we get the
marketing ready and all that always
stops being music dollars will keep
recording public cities
stay in that zone yes I love that I fell
out before I got off music and stars you
know like being yours marketing and
thinking about selling me see yeah it's
like paying for getting back in music
mode you know so while you're in it
you're staying on time I make myself at
home
uh-huh questions do you think of that
opportunity is something that everybody
has access to resumes I think that every
today's world there's no more old white
guy being the gatekeeper so everybody's
got a map back I just don't think
everybody's got it like that but I think
everybody can maximize their [ __ ] listen
I love playing basketball I'm not
[ __ ] LeBron you know what I mean like
so I like we've all got our talents but
you know what you guys do for look like
I mean I'm looking at music and I'm
spending a lot of time looking at it
[ __ ] SoundCloud Spotify putting music
on vlogs like no more Jimmy Iovine
[ __ ] trips over you no more [ __ ]
like you got your [ __ ] one song away
on like putting out [ __ ] like and like
and you don't even need rap caviar you
just need to put out music and I think
the one bear above the [ __ ] that I
[ __ ] trade on is trade culture if
you're hungry and like trying to think
about your career like you just it's so
hungry right now where you're at young
and like right and what's going through
your life thing sure that went through
my mind thirty times you say in yourself
in your mind this project specially with
this man this project oh this is what
it's going to be this is what it's going
to happen and guess what it might not
like for me if I'm in music I wish I
could rap because I know I could be
humongous because all I would do is make
music and then lay in bed for 11 hours
try to hack on social media get in my
[ __ ] recognized notice you're one person
away one piece of content away you just
got to [ __ ] make it and what's
amazing about music and I can't I think
everybody I don't like speaking about
[ __ ] I don't know so I don't to speak to
it but one thing I do know is I believe
that every artist that ever lived had a
lot more songs in their [ __ ] dome
they never saw the day of life because
of the way it worked right now
everybody's fancy everybody's trying to
understand supply and demand I don't
think people understand how busy the
world is the world's so busy there's so
much [ __ ]
that I'm a big fan of telling people to
put out music put out music like [ __ ]
every week like if you've got it like
that you know some people don't have it
I don't know but if you got it like that
put it out put it out people are hungry
for it and every time you put out that's
giving you another at-bat I think there
will be a big-time artist in next decade
that puts out a song a day I agree with
that we didn't camp interaction called
Marathon Monday we got the song mmm-hmm
some I saw the reaction to that more
selling dropping a hundred I'm telling
right now somebody's gonna wake up and
do something called 365 and are starting
[ __ ] January first and they're gonna
[ __ ] go the reason I love 365 is you
can social commentate like what people
love is relevance right like I don't
know how do you write or you just go
from the dome I do both
right so for me like like just culture
right like Game seven of the NBA Finals
like you slip a little like nobody can
beat you to the market you're just
dropping [ __ ] that everybody give the
[ __ ] about something pops on [ __ ]
Instagram and everyone's talking about
just one little line that's what Kooks
people it's what hooks it you know real
climbing it just to have that discipline
and to put yourself out there like to
put yourself out there like yo I'm gonna
actually do this that's hard that's a
risk but like the reward I'm all about
risk reward right I did a sneakers like
all upside the sneaker I got coming out
like if it fails like nobody expects a
40 year old [ __ ] entrepreneur to have
a hot kick right but if it works right I
[ __ ] it at 2,000 people at shoe palace
on Melrose Tuesday night and the owner
Walken is like there's more people here
than we drop the easies everybody heard
that and that's that's it that's what I
keep doing right and the best part is
you just have that humility if there was
six people there but like I lost and
that's just when you get to that place
where you just don't get [ __ ] about what
anybody else thinks that's how you put
up with here 265 music right right
because that's Sunday February 9th you
put out something ok and people like
black lack you should have done this
project and that's when you get punched
in the [ __ ] mouth and are you going
to [ __ ] drink
that blood and just record the next day
and [ __ ] get them or you gonna fold
like a cheap chair and be like [ __ ] me
so get the right DNA to go for those
kind of projects
I don't do there's anyone in hip-hop to
really change things like Nicki can and
the other thing about it is I've seen
you speak a couple times and then I've
spoken to a few people in the tech
roaders like set up these speaking
engagements at these conferences you
know Geragos speaks all those speaks all
the time cream when I saw him speak it
was like I've heard a lot of people say
the same type of stuff I've never
understood it until I heard him say
and so like because of your first-hand
experience and then because of your view
like your point of view and just the way
you are able to communicate to people
and just have people understand things
and then like the stuff you're doing
with the clothing and then when you I
watch the video when you were in the
Starbucks and you met I I yeah and uh
now he's like your CTO and he had some
technology on the starbuck table and I
had my daughter I was getting into the
bathroom and it was like she said I
hadn't seen before it was like reading a
bone structure of his hand off of a LCD
and he start explaining that it was arm
up tongue is driving I was on it sober
basically by us sitting down after that
means yeah you know he begs me opened my
mind up to how we can where we intersect
as far as tech and as far as hip-hop and
culture news like Tech is oxygen of our
society right I don't think people
understand like I'm sure you're gonna
understand this
we're everybody in this room looking at
how everyone's quite young we're all
going to live in a mixed reality world
contact lenses where we're sitting here
right now [ __ ] POC and VR and it's
sitting right here with us like people
don't understand Oh clue they think
shits crazy now we haven't even started
this is the [ __ ] national anthem of a
19 inning game like people having wrap
their head around how [ __ ] up [ __ ] is
going to be are you doing are you
[ __ ] around blockchain yet you
enjoying it you hack it on top of the
theory I'm yet now yeah like but it's
caught your eye right yeah that shit's
got a big [ __ ] and that's why I'm
trying to push you and your young man
here and everybody to debate this
idea if the world is in an issue of
supply and demand then why not have the
thesis of just [ __ ] pound an outcome
I'm a man follow me
what you memorized what's the issue is
flying tonight there's so much supply of
content that you can never be
overexposed because everyone's getting
pulled at so many directions so the
reason nobody want to put out so much
music we're overexposure overexposure
that [ __ ] doesn't exist
there's nobody overexposed because
everybody's getting pulled in so many
directions do people just evolve to take
more info hey that's for damn sure
but even at scale I think that you can't
be overexposed as an artist if you're
capable about putting out a song every
day right and that's where everyone's
[ __ ] up that's right you know how it
used to be right you come out you do
your thing then you [ __ ] disappear
got to keep that balance right can come
right I think that shit's so competitive
there's so much great content there's so
much [ __ ] going on that if you've got it
like that you gotta go you gotta go but
you know I was interesting because if
I'm working with my future pop I'd [ __ ]
gears and we're my raw [ __ ] gears and I
won so Jennifer come on Barbara let's
shut this thing
Shep okay simile how are you real
pleasure
it was the impound and just dropping
music running dropping when you say
great look coach [ __ ] music creek
without right it's a lot of [ __ ]
music by standards of what we all grew
up with he's put out more music in 24
months but people put out in our careers
I think the exercycle is the quality if
you can manufacture well this comes down
to talent right like this is my thing
with you like like you got to push the
boundaries of how talented argue run our
losses right like how just how talented
are you there's always like like
especially something as [ __ ]
culturally relevant and this passion is
art you guys do art like like if you've
got it in you to do it then you do it
some people don't some people have
different processes right they got out
like you can't force it but if you've
got it if your notebook is fold full if
it's full with bangers you need to put
that [ __ ] out it can't be like Prince
and you [ __ ] when we find them dead
we go in a safe and there's a 100
great song you know that day doesn't
exist anymore hey man NJ didn't have it
like they couldn't do that data wait
every three years to put out a Lebanon
anything anybody does somebody else
aspires to do like know like like it
just gonna work like that back in a day
Oh business man you know what a 41 year
old white businessman look like in
culture 20 years ago right yeah same
with producers right but who is talking
about producers 30 years ago
the Internet's literally came along and
leveled like not even level the playing
field Gabe gave the you notice it it ate
up the distribution of everything and
and then took nothing for it and is
paying out to groups of people the
biggest ballers who built on top of it
Facebook Google right because they just
don't it's basically like the internet
is like the land and lever Facebook and
Google did was like build the trains and
the plans but all the artists like
everybody with the IP the leverage
they're getting the dollars no more
middle middle men have to bring so much
value now which is great can't just sit
and be like cool right that's it and
there's merit to it the people that
deserve it or get it and having it
started you know what I noticed the
Marion I want here Pinterest I I've
noticed that every idea that I've had
whether as a drum kit or the podcast or
whatever was passed the auxin they're
all things that I felt like would end up
being really fun to do and and so my
kind of philosophy I'm adopting now is
like if it's fun fun it's probably you
know why that happens it's a it's a
bigger macro situation because it's fun
you're willing to work your face off and
working your face off is actually the
gateway it's not the fun the fun is the
doorway that gets you to put in the work
that gets you the results because d-roc
loves filming like the 24/7 nature of
what he does is you know is what so many
kids want to film into this but they
don't want to it's not fun enough for
them you have to love it
cost of entry now is if you understand
you have to look like for me building
brands whether it's my own brand brands
for other people other things why it's
so the only thing I gave a [ __ ] about
that I'm willing to put in the nineteen
that it takes because the problem is now
with the internet like what you're
saying being the middleman and everybody
can play there's some kid in Kansas City
who's going to put in the nineteen right
money put in twenty and I don't want any
I don't want any of you little [ __ ] to
take my [ __ ] now what's amazing is
though the biggest thing I didn't know
is that some fun but there's so much
that all those little [ __ ] that are
going to put in the nineteen are going
to get theirs too and that makes me
happy yeah so I would say funds a great
gateway to fun is the precursor to
ridiculous amount of work which then
gets you there yeah right
how often do you like balance that for
yourself how often is it fun and often
is it not fun as long as macro fun
I recognize micro [ __ ] exists like
Tuesday might suck March might suck
20:18 like suck a macro it's fun and
when you get to that perspective you
stops you don't slow down when Tuesday
March are a year is [ __ ] and that's why
most people lose because they stop
either an hour into not going well a day
a week a month got it so don't get
crippled like nothing's perfect every
second yeah the best things are
nothing's perfect but having the
understanding that macro like what else
would you rather be doing exactly
exactly and then we start complaining
about dumb [ __ ] right meanwhile you're
playing the game of your dreams like
little you growing up in Newark if you
would have showed this down you and dr.
Dre come on it's crazy every time so
that's it you know what I mean
so I'm perspective out
cincin what's so great about media now
right like ten years ago with a matter
the car let's chop it up and if you turn
down like boom let's put them on brown
bags we put out content like turned
yourself into a media company you can
always do stuff always do stuff right
okay so it's so fun and it's so fix are
so high stakes are so high the people
that don't grab this [ __ ] by the neck
over the next two decades I'm gonna sit
back and be like what the [ __ ] was I
thinking how did I not see it what he's
doing he might be he he he took
something that used to be like held
secret and he opened sourced it and
created an API and so he's scaling like
a tech company got it put it like that
and that's what I'm doing the business
knowledge and the ideas I have I'm
sharing them with the world for free
this is stuff people used to sell this
is stuff a bunch of losers are selling
now and are giving you nothing there's
stuff that I get paid tens of millions
of dollars for and I'm giving it to
these [ __ ] for free if the world I
just sit on their ass and watch it a
little bit on YouTube like that is
incredible that's why I have power
that's why so many people show up I'm
getting the best shipper free yeah
that's funny because I think I love love
love love love love love shake hideaway
for free throws
yeah it's leverage yeah listen everybody
close their eyes and think about the
person that brings you the most like
happiness and love and value you're
always trying to be around that person
got you gonna be here tonight thank you
thank you
I am yo I thank you I usually manage a
group that you're used in a song and one
of your back your video saunder
someone's on Saunders
I love soldiers oh yeah can you rock how
are you I'm great
I'm gonna mine Jacqueline Jacqueline I
can meet you yeah it was you're doing
all the work towards thanks for loving
it thank you
what do you guys have to
dr. Ghali this place and incubator right
and that's why if I get a photos of
course know what your name I'm tired
time silly I talk about you all the time
to my boss Thank You Man really like
inspiration and a lot of people such a
pleasure thank you for a lot take care
this is Sir
oh man seriously keep doing it you
inspire me so far Thank You Man thank
you so much for the love thank you
ticket or several you're not coming up
thinking about right yeah let's go let's
go Canaries I'm not trying to hold your
shop enough I'm working we're all these
coasts we can't have any tired my man
was like that's really I'll see you I'll
see you in September we're gonna walk
you in for brown bags
I'll see we got the data register
hopefully you're around if not we'll do
in October oh yeah it's definitely do
that huh
good day I smell like a weed you do I do
some Angeles City - hi thank you
I'll juice to do Nipsey Hussle good
melmac smelling great day cruisin today
you've been having a good week good man
yeah everyone's been like good right you
guys been on - Raja get up broken tables
and chairs we got here we cleared it out
or get Kenny Scharf this guy's in
museums over the world rulers tearing
vascular it's not it's not right
Christmas cooking installation here this
out and and it's all wrong
it's all let me like you guys I got high
point your career right humbly yes how
much if we can do it like if I came when
you guys were sleeping and cut this out
and sold this late hello pull anything
I think it's last one was thinking you
know there's a 10 mm thank you for that
with the shot when you're sleeping
tomorrow when I send Babbitt area and
drill this out I can get like 30 for it
yeah okay this piece so in yours but
this hole but this will be right
oh yeah New York innocent OID I got my
club gallery exactly we were like we
should just like meals a little nest
back here we call it and so what you
guys this was just broken table it's
what your boys with this guy yeah yeah
clear which we represent him and help it
Geils right got and it was like whoa I
built and I feel a big mural for you can
you know we can bring people through it
easier or whatever it's all black light
as well so at night it goes up but this
is if you Google keep it up Kenny Scharf
it's just photos Basquiat Haring Warhol
that's the crew in him it's the only one
that's alive Yoshi show Peppa the only
one who didn't die yeah that's the only
reason why he did not tear that out last
year right when he dies yeah yeah okay
babban when this - that wasn't me ah
using your get me tell me though and
it's a joke yes yeah when you kill them
yes I and this is like a read models but
the fetus comes and glues the [ __ ] on
time it's been going it's insane and he
lives out here yeah he lives you can see
our flag from his house and we do like
different already's up here I had a wine
thing that small wine sponsor going
I even have like different wine glasses
hey uh Tyler Kinect kid Garcia Phil I
know you're so close to this oh yeah
let's do something proper here to get
some more exposure
okay so flag was broken for 10 years I
had it fixed into one day off Craigslist
and now we can put anything we wanted at
any time at any time so like a Gary be
like a Gary because I was going to make
one by those too much yeah nothing's too
much by the way okay through next time
yeah unreal views my boy do you learn
the laugh Olympics
oh I kick it in can somebody Google
laugh Olympics I know I'm saying it
right no the laugh Olympics it was like
the yogi yahooeys versus the scooby
doobies versus the rotten scoundrels and
it was like this Olympics of all the
cartoon characters I used to watch it on
USA back in I didn't do this right LAF
last yeah what is it what does it say
like what it was I knew I was right when
did the air
serious when is a spoof of the Olympics
1977 suits the Olympics and the ABC
television series battle of the Network
Stars yep and it featured 45
hanna-barbera characters organization to
do the job yogi yahooeys and I'm really
wrong [ __ ] nail that give me some it
was [ __ ] it was the best cartoon
have you guys seen this whole new trend
all these like 18 year olds can't
believe that you can use an antenna to
watch TV I thought it today I did I saw
that what is an antenna yeah like people
like you feel like getting a free TV
yeah
they like their own like if you search
it on Twitter like yo yeah you free TV
thank you really how it's called an
antenna sure sure
it's so it's so fun the way the world
works the world is actually divided
right now in a way that we've never seen
there's like two worlds playing out
there's just like the mobile culture and
like everything that's real there and
then the other one yeah the one that's
in trouble everything else tell us about
your company of what you do for your
minds
hey guys Gary Vaynerchuk CEO vaynermedia
alexa askgaryvee crazy how we get around
so Miss Gary Gary I seen you I think
like a podcast yep yep Junie - bright
nice to meet you man take care yourself
thanks for love man I never get involved
in content right I was like laughing I'm
like I wonder what babbit sick or like
or like Jake that was Jake and then I
got involved in yours too I literally
want to avoid I want to destroy Atlanta
what I love you Andy you don't get
enough love make sure to spin the clip
hey what's up with my stuff what do they
do really like gangster men and they
accepted the else I know that you're a
week all the new stuff it'll come I
think that they hate that I don't care
for what they've done
I moved out to Kitty Kotik that I call
my son they say they don't love me but
I've known anything along I know that's
always awesome new stuff and everybody
loves that I don't care for what they've
done
I moved out to City patek Telecom haha
they did all of you I'm not a single Oh
I did it I did it right been looking out
for the new what do you like that that's
good right I love that I want to get set
up here in the house
la put some chilies Birds chopping it up
all day in LA
ah top it's in my mouth dude you're
talking to this work work work what's a
fossil my favorite number oh my lucky
ass number I'm glad it's not sick Freddy
sevens ready for anything good and smart
cities babbles what you guys don't know
you - is that this man is the man behind
your de loved' beloved be rock - love it
well I like that not look I know I'm a
little behind us and not behind you
meaning you're you did are you all right
yeah you're right you're basically
finished you know we can just finish out
the question you know my biggest thing
that I want people leave with is how
ridiculously impossible it is to be a
human being and how grateful everybody
should be and to realize that your
grandparents did not have it this good
this internet thing that did just second
nature to us it's fundamentally the
biggest thing that has ever happened to
the human being and Steve if you can't
eliminate your excuses and do something
about here one life you're going to
regret it and regret scares the [ __ ] out
of me or so if you need with anything
please squeeze the [ __ ] out of your life
to get only one at that dirty baby like
this talk about it for me to talk about
it all these different friends I got all
fanatics and they all sing along all
events in every songs of automatic loss
Pentatonix business all my songs going
against a life you gave me Morris all
right you can't start a from the sites
Christ our race afraid it's a but like
I've been reborn to think they're gone
they're lightweight with the Christ I
rise above it they say that I like it
but I know they love it I know that your
way
it'll come I think that they hate that I
don't care for what they've done
[Music]